[Music]  hey baby  [Music]  a neti I need five copies of this yep  hey Ned sorry to bother you  thank you a huge favor I need five  copies of this Oh that'd be great  Thanks hey hon hey Caitlin your hair  looks amazing  oh thank you wait hey what's up hey man  are you gonna looking out you look good  yeah actually  thanks that's so cool I'm so glad Ryan  and we're not really talking anymore oh  my god what happened let's talk about it  yeah yeah last Monday was when it got  really weird hey so I haven't seen  Amanda around lately  you guys all right we're not really  talking at the moment so guys another  round yes yes okay what okay cheesecake  [Applause]  [Laughter]  are you sure you're not cold no I want  you to have it  so how was your day good  how was yours good just today  [Music]